the journey to marriage is filled with
uneasy excitements if that is the story
you wish to hear
I said I'm alaikum guys before I start
this video in sha Allah I want to ensure
a thank our sponsor mini Muslim the
doctor at UK do check them out they're
gonna be learning it's gonna be a
description box below that's why for
this little mini camera here which can
put the kids toys in there as you can
see and these symbols these symbols here
are very important as your children are
growing up or babies for newborns as
well as you can see something that
things that they can play with they send
me this a long time ago I supposed to a
long time ago about Jenna didn't have
time but hamdulillah it came to this
video so inshallah baby bedtime
lullabies and Quran very very important
bonuses for us to install this in our
kids at a young age before it's too late
let's get insha'Allah straight into the
video and Sharla do check them out we
have newborns or family members gifts
check them out of Shaba let's get
straight into the video as you guys know
a controversial matter from a couple on
Instagram that they have decided to come
as a family and decided that the sister
and the brother decided that he wants to
get married again and if and they've
chosen on that and he's going on got
married again but Brahman sisters when
it comes to polygamy obviously we have
to be very very careful to not make rash
decisions and I'm totally disagree with
the way they went about it because
polemic polygamy can work and sometimes
it does ruin lives as well so I totally
disagree with the way they went about it
and drop the inshallah so I wanna make
that very clear now I'll be discussing
this matter in a few angles yeah bowel
make something I wanna make a disclaimer
in no way shape or form of my endorsing
this couple
am i endorsing anything they do yes I
appreciate in value that they call for
marriage in this time of zina in this
error of zina left right center
Bilbo's wherever you look Xena Xena Xena
everywhere yeah I appreciate and value
that they promote Highland
marriage gathering any coming together
in marriage yeah I appreciate Valley
I've done a video before yeah but I want
to make a disclaimer that in no way
shape or form does that mean I endorse
everything they do that they I mean no
no no no no sir let's make that very
very clear no way shape or form I
encourage all into a single however I'm
not going to be like those who have been
Tamia they all have mercy instead but
some of them some people are not flies
they seem they're not good in people
Oh
see is the bad they leveled the bad the
poo you no clue I'm sorry they learned
on the pappu
they love bad places because they're not
friends they never see any good in
people
I don't want to be that their good
outweighs their bad from what I can see
however I have a advice for them also
I've advanced with them also and also
have an advice for everyone so lesson
listen carefully
let's go to the so this is she always he
should release that they got married and
she put out there'll be a backlash in
the second post a sister comments and
those if she likes to share her man's
private parts I'm not gonna mention it
then allowing should allow herself to be
disrespected by her husband and friend
she'll turn anything for the sake of
Allah but knows not respect herself as a
mother and a woman of Allah
either way you would only affect their
children blah blah blah blah etcetera
etcetera
I find this comment and many comments
disgusting yeah it's actually viable for
this this is to think that polygamy is
just about sharing your husband's
private parts it's a bit disturbing
because another marriage relationship is
more than that I'm going to come to the
pros and cons of of polygamy but I'm
just saying in general it's a disgusting
statement and for the beam brothers
getting gassy and excited and the
sisters heartbroken scene we saw you as
a couple I do a couple and it broken our
dreams which I'm still trying to find
that why
and I'm going like once again I said I'm
not endorsing I'm not on their side to
see that won't succumb so be patient
with me are you guys are in rage in here
but what I find funny is the same love
to extreme the Liberals and the shooter
on Belize the other super everything you
cannot believe oxygen is Haram yeah and
then we have other liberals for them
everything is Highland everything is
Helen dia every Salah polygamy is Haram
yeah okay by the way so they think
they're from the police yeah
so now the thing is then it Bruce when
it comes to our religion when I come to
homosexuality
by the way we don't conduct the inside
kind of an eye towards them weather
comes homosexuality
when it comes to you [ __ ] worshipping
other than allah subhanho wa taala when
it comes to innovation in the religion
when I come to a certain religion major
sin etc the youtubes that they follow
that new commit commit sins they clap
woohoo amazing but when a couple who
come together made a decision
moving forward in a something that is
Highland fully halal they used to plop
they lose the plot absolutely mental
when I was in Scotland I felt like
somebody committed ship
do you know [ __ ] is it worse than
anything on this planet anything that
you can think is even a disgusting [ __ ]
is worse than that a sushi upon us a lot
of wood is worse than that so I'm just a
bit baffled where our priorities are so
for our liberal brothers and sisters I
relate with you in a way where the way
when they went about it was wrong and
I'm gonna come to them I'm gonna come to
that but but also one thing is is that
these comments are absolutely vile
disgusting if two up one has made a
decision that their partner wants to get
married again for me and you you know
what we need to do Shh
none of your business some of you
sisters are acting and behaving like
it's your husband that's gonna married
again like look look you have a right to
not run it for yourself even otherwise
some scholar so if you see that you can
even stiffly in the contracts these well
let's get married again some say that
some say no you can't but don't make
some fig Helen Haram and when the
homilies don't make was Haram was hella
her and vice versa
now there is also a lot of stronger
coming about a lot of slander going
about now this is a book from chef Sal
and frozen yeah okay chefs a lot fellas
on some love Islamic jurisprudence yeah
this is the punishment first one I want
to talk about something this is the
reason why I want to have a sauna
because there's accusations that are
being made towards this couple yes this
these people I don't know if they are
true or not but according to the Sharia
Allah says in the core and if I'm saving
a surah Noor when I should have your
honor the prophets wife was slandered
why did they believe in men and woman
did not feel good of themselves why did
they not think good why is it that we
were binoculars like wait for them to
make that mistake and these issues going
about that the sister was
is a model and all these kind of
accusations yeah okay to me I'm sorry
I've got me real Islamically the
pictures that you up in skin sent
pictures this picture no she's heard
your job search is going out etc in the
eyes of allah subhanaw taala you're a
kebab liar you're a liar you're a liar
sorry you are a liar you are a liar
according to the Sharia it doesn't work
like that and to the stand our season
token time in this book and those who
accuse chaste women and then do not
produce for witnesses lash them lash
them 80 lashes and do not accept from
them any testimony ever after those and
those are defining this video yeah one
of the one of the seven destructive sins
is sounded a chaste woman or a man and
these are the consequences the legal
punishment for Sandra and this one is
lashing the rejection of his testimony
and considering him considering him and
defined the disobedient wicked person as
long as he does not prove what he is
claimed as for his punishment in the
hereafter it is stated in the verse in
which Allah insulted me says indeed
those who forsake his chaste underwear
and believing woman are close in this
world and in the hereafter they would
have great punishment on the day when
their tongues their hands and the feet
will bear witness against them as to
what they used to do that day Allah will
pay them in therefore in in food a tree
recovery company and they will not say
and they will know that it is Allah who
was the man of history and perfect and
justice these accusations are massive
accusations now if this comes out and if
it's true and it can be established
Islamically not I saw CCTV camera not I
saw pictures and it looked like her it
was her eyes or conceived from the
jacket and the background if you go to
this time because you will get lashed
like his happy days they will get you
lashed it's not that it's a massive deal
to accuse somebody of anything so please
for the sake of all this want to feel
also panettone unless you have a disease
in your heart against somebody and
you're looking for his mistake then you
have a problem up here the problems up
here if you're jealous but because of
sin issues then the problem is with you
I personally when it comes it should
click in here in my mind's documentary
person myself I was approached for
polygamy yes I was I'll be honest to you
I
in a decent way some inappropriate which
I think probably comes approach you in a
decent way you know kind of would you
would you want to be in a pelican living
this marriage can I be your caller
exactly who did this stuff I discuss it
in my much documentary
yeah okay my views on it how I feel
about it how it's being misused I'm
gonna be talking all about it I'm gonna
be interviewing systems that were used
yes BRABUS who use it the other end well
as you abuse this marry divorce marry
divorce sisters using abuse they've
chucked him away yeah passed him around
to their friend yeah what are we talking
about what this car this is the disgust
evil side of it yeah and none of the
actors in the collision is evil but what
these brothers are doing and we know and
some citizen promise hate it because of
those who misuse it and we understand
but in general I admire and I honor I
honor and admire a man a man who was
truthful and he has he says look I'm a
polygamous man yeah I had my own honor
the man who would go and see to his wife
look darling this is something that
you're not gonna like but I would rather
tell you this and go about it the right
way then go and do Haram I'm sorry I
admire and honor such a man now in this
country is not allowed yeah let's not
allow you can have your friends you can
have side shift you have mistresses you
can abuse women as much as you like have
girlfriends left right center but get
married again no I believe is hypocrisy
I believe polygamy is a solution for
mankind it might be hard you might be
hard for our sisters of course but also
we can claim say the same as men look
why do men have to go why did in World
War two men have to go more why do you
go because it was a female why do you go
what there's things that we may not like
that we have to do you might not like
but it's there for a better reason but
it's up to you to choose - my point is
this in this country non-muslim men
practice polygamy they have girlfriends
and mistresses and side shifts and they
use it abuse girls and they have the
girlfriend and they have their wife
Islam says it's there to legislate it in
the right way so if a man wants to get
married again he wanders the wife and
says look by this is what I want to do
etc etc etc he honors himself and obeys
the law of is
by not going to committing zina adultery
yep going against the laws of allah
subhanaw taala
he goes and does it in a right way and
honors the woman he wants to marry a
mother going to her dad the wedding
doing it properly in a hiline man not
using I let me buy you a Gucci bag
aparadha you know about you this
lipstick and Bobby Brown whether you
wanna call it you know I use it for a
bit take in a few holidays and bye-bye
I've used you goodbye no it has to be
done in the right way I also admire more
the sister the sister or the wife that
allows it because I know how much is a
big thing for a female I know so
regarding this issue nobody can come and
say it's Haram nobody because it if then
Haram nobody can see in another however
however the way you guys went about it I
know cuz you guys been watching
inshallah
maybe I'm sure you guys gonna watch it
together both the Buffett and his two
wives become probably watch it together
yeah the way you went about it was wrong
I knew that there are an says do not
tell the people what they are not ready
to hear do you want them to disbelieve
in Allah His Messenger now why did he
say that why did I run the iron finally
need to say that because shackle because
they mean explains to us that when you
make this thing when you go to people
and say something to them and especially
just random you just pop in a picture
it's not wise like brother and sisters
not watching it's not wise for you to
God just drop it like that if he was
gonna do it you have a process a whole
video this is what we decided this is
the reason it's not for everyone
you can't just drop it like that because
you've done two things in your comment
section there is statements of offer
being uttered that's when you showed us
why because you have caused that
indirectly because when you say there
shall be no payment explains that if you
say to somebody that a statement and as
a muslim generates here they're gonna
say you're liar whoever said that is a
liar i would appeal now online as
messenger said it so do you see how you
are causing them to utter words of offer
why because they're not ready to hear it
there's a gentleman he says there's a
step-by-step process to explain in it
the second fingers think you can
actually
them to see and I I reject this I reject
this I'm never accepting this from into
this belief you've cause somebody to
leave the fault of Islam so when you do
stuff like this you have a
responsibility I've said this from day
one brothers and sisters if you guys are
a public figure on Instagram
you have a responsibility you can't just
come our left right center and after
this and done that it's not right it's
wrong so me personally I would say that
was room that was wrong for you guys to
drop in like that if you're gonna do it
too in the proper way explain it well
how you keep that decision etc you know
but you have you come into town no but
with this aspect I don't if is Jara Jara
what you've done you cause people to
stay in stem is offer now another issue
is that you guys do Rocio your Rockies
if I'm not mistaken yet now you guys
should know better you guys should know
well well better you know even I exist
so yeah II I understand you guys are
trying to show certain things but you
know there's a comment that you made you
post you made a key that you say oh it's
okay to take your wife behind the bush
every now and then and then you explain
it but it's a dirty state menarche it's
a dirty statement yeah I know what you
meant and yeah but it's a steady state
manake and i would advise you please
abstain okay because there's some things
you do that's inappropriate like you
were like people miss me laughs i send
it to refute guys i don't i assume the
best I'm not one of those people that
die and look for refutation but
seriously there's certain things please
be considerate have limits enough yes we
understand
you put my marriage good but you know
have limits and showing off nothing is
showing off but I'm saying showing
people out there you know you do Rukia
you should know better
yeah you don't need to show every single
think of your life probably advice for
me to you guys and other thing is I
messaged you guys which I'm a little bit
of Sarah and I just since I'm talking
about this is that you guys do rakia and
you know how evil music is and I message
your first wife our sister and I respect
I mention a respectful manner you can
see the message there and I miss you
see I assume the best way you watch
syrup you're playing music drinks yeah
that song hey Kiki I love you whatever
hell it was here and you actually
playing the music okay can you do Rukia
your Rocky how does this work I don't
understand is that me trying to help
people to quit smoking and I give them
cigarette you know the music that effect
music has so why do you the anok it
looks contradictory Aki
you know I'm me problem just advising
you you know hope you understand
inshallah yeah cuz I've privately advice
you as well and another thing for those
who you know what neither Rock you're
done I'm calling this Rocky's whoever
you can do Rukia on yourself we done a
video with my teacher I'll link the
video
why do you guys if you believe that
these Rocky's have some kind of
superpowers like a Dragon Ball Z and
fire comes out and they have this
special one like this this can be maybe
- [ __ ] this can be actually Janna Cooper
they don't have the power they recited
for an you can do this to yourself
and for those Iraqis who are charging
ridiculous amounts ridiculous amount
they talking mafioso panettone I've
heard of stories with again 50 people
together and charged in a 50 pound each
and they doing like a mass think Rukia
session come on Murphy allah subhanaw
taala
well my fear was subhana wa taala we
have to Yanni
please and I'm telling you guys well
like you can do it on yourself
you can do it somebody can do it on you
you can do on yourself if you getting
this perception that this person has
superpowers what lying you're falling
into dangerous places yeah going to this
PSR p.m. sweep us up yeah give this yeah
every day's per blow on this do this and
most of the times these Rocky's they're
not qualified they are not qualified and
I'm not talking about them I'm talking
generally not qualified they speak they
do are the genius inside the gene is
lying to them your auntie did this in
Pakistan auntie did nothing and they're
causing fit between the families so we
talk about super Masha I don't go into
too much detail and in a nutshell I want
to ensure that once again say that what
they have done is not Haram it is Helen
it is halal regarding the law of the
land
well I I believe Janna could do it too
like actual
illegal marriage in this country's
allowed he do two of them this allowed
Thea so gay and married again
I don't know that Specter figure okay
but like I said to you like I said to
you before sisters it might be hard to
swallow etc by the end of the day we
know some situation of sisters you go
and say to their husbands did she come
come it's you know but I don't want to
know and going this will be abuzz loss
go tarnish Allah's law stomper there's a
trumpet trumpet on it but no don't mean
I'm sorry
yeah brothers and sisters this issue is
a big issue it can be misused there's
pros and cons of polygamy yeah if it's
misused there is but if this couple are
happy me and you should be quiet Shh
none of your business
and but again then for this couple
please you don't have to put everything
out there you don't need to put
everything out there so that's it that's
it really brothers and sisters in sha
allah may allah bless you guys for
watching till next time assalamu alaikum
what I meant already better care to
inshallah
let's keep everything holiday inshallah